区 u 様の家のズボンそろそろ買ったほうがいいよマークイズカモン
あのマークイズっていうの近くに沿っピングモールがあるんですよ
1万皆さんコンビニとかお店とかレストランとかでべっしートっていうものをもらった
ことがあると思うんですけども今までもらってきたでシード一番長いのってどれくらい
ありますか
この僕はちょっと人とは違うのでまぁ2m ぐらいのレシートもらったことあるんです
けども2m
てくれシートを使い切ると思うとか嬉しい朝長サーブか
いるっあったらやなでうれしいとてなか世界共通感ある我々まずであるじゃんあれない
ないかないかもしれない待って目シートの世界記録がないじゃないようなよねぇないな
あ
はっはっは
まということは俺が今ここで得た外れの謎のレシートを作った小灌木予報
世界記録保持者になるということですよねそうですねっていうわけでもレシートの長さ
を求めるとお店の人に迷惑かかってうれしい
髪を8日とも長いレシートをもらおうと思うとお店の人に迷惑かかるて自分でね次回
ました
背景でもこれ祭嬉しいと思っていますそれでも商品を売って
ています
本体はもうレシートが出てくるんですよ
こういう感じでねレシートってどうやったら長くなるかって言うとそう品が多ければ
多いほどその品僕が増えてるわけですよ今だったらこれ後する妹のを買ってこの長さに
なったんで空想品が多くなればいってことはこれでたくさん総理を買えばいいんですよ
たくさん商品化ってこうやって金額って
お会計したらお金足りないそれは買うと
って
練習とか長くなるわけでございます意図的に僕も世界最大の長さのレシートを作ろうと
した時に注文する商品の数を多くしまくってお会計すれば多分世界最大の中その
レシートは作れるんじゃないかというわけでちょっとが現世に挑んでみますは二話以降
入ってあげてやっていきましょう臭が半端な長さともダメなんで目シートの永里へ最大
にしておきたいんでロールのな方は
[音楽]
ブーブーいますウードゥー
でかっ
あレジバー宝庫リーズ登録できません
えっ
もう限界やっぱりこのネジの県外の誰だもう6日客入ってんですね101点注文した
ところでネジが止まってしまいました
考える俺ネジを伸ばす方向お支払いのお金の数おい添え長くしたらゼロの桁によって
レシートが長くなる
例えば今溶岩発生4発電の階級王者んですけども4万果て良い数順
とかお金を出さなきゃいけないんですけどもそこ1億円にしたら999051520円
のお釣りになるんでそこでこのゼロとかいろんな風の keter でレシーブでも
なんかまた勝てると思うのでちょっと金額を高めにお支払いしましょう
100選まあ字幕てきます千万1億
ねっ強く100億
戦1丁ずっ町百町山町
えっ無限じゃああッ
あっあ無理だな前回1位の値まで来ませんタブでも10兆円くらいのお金を出せると
思うのでこのままだ多分90球と9年999を宮殿995万1520円のおつりが生え
てくるんでレシートはかなり長くなるはずだ
を掛けいっ
あった黒
えっ
じゃ
もう1回やり直しですああああ
[音楽]
きた後でお会計
率10%逆転マン妻いても打てないちょくちょく
動く
泉屋一丁10町百町
船長あれ
d っっ
無限大水っていうのはこれを書いていこうと思いますこれがそれがとりあえず俺の見て
きた中で一番長いレシートになることを祈って
他ゲー
れ恋ゲー
いやな花はぁ
ちょちょちょちょ
きちゃっ
ほほほ
あれ
うんっ
1メートル上流19違うって
ブーブー言っ日って商品の名前を長くする女性費の金額自体退けた
かなり多くしました999999商品の値段が取る相撲水数が少なすぎなのでそういう
その品名とか値段で結果を出せれより長いレシートをつくれるか試してみようと思い
ます前
5回被害は900万9,791円ですね幼いが
よしっおかげ
ファッ
me
re あった